delays and mixed messages have hampered
the federal government's response to the
coronavirus yesterday CBS Evening News
anchor Norah O'Donnell asked President
Trump about one of the biggest
challenges health and human services
secretary Alex azar has said around four
million tests will be distributed by the
end of this week but so far only about
8,500 tests have been performed and
secretary a czar joins us now secretary
good morning good morning good morning
you said that the testing is difficult
to track because wall tests have been
sent out they're sent out to private
labs and those labs don't report back to
the CDC or to your department why has
not why has that tracking not been more
careful so this is the system we have in
the United States we have sent out over
1.1 million tests we have another 2
million tests that are either being
shipped or are waiting to be ordered so
we actually have a surplus of testing
capacity in the United States right now
the numbers that you quoted are simply
the tests that have been conducted by
CDC's labs in Atlanta or by public
health labs using the CDC test but
that's not really the relevant metric
the relevant metric is going to be how
many positive cases do we get and we
always get that data mr. secretary why
is it taking so long to build that
system to monitor this and to get the
tests out it actually hasn't you know we
had the test right away as soon as we
got the genetic sequence from China and
we have had capacity to test throughout
this there has not been an instance
where a public health official needed to
test somebody for the novel coronavirus
where they couldn't get tested we've
always had the tests up and running at
CDC in Atlanta they work with our public
health lab network we've had other
public health labs up and running what
we're doing now though is expanding the
testing to make sure it's ever closer to
the patient ever closer to the doctor
and hospital and just as convenient as
humanly possible can you guarantee that
any doctor who wants to get a test can
easily any duck any doctor who believes
that a test is clinically indicated can
get that test done there is no barrier
whatsoever from the federal government
in terms of getting that done so mr. a
is let's talk about risk because that's
really what everyone wants to know about
Mike Pence and the coronavirus task
force has been saying over and over
again that for the typical American the
risk remains low but the CDC is saying
in its latest update that many people
will be exposed this virus spreads
easily and rapidly and that there's a
good chance people will become sick so
when we talk about risk what are we
really talking about well it's a good
question there are two types of risk the
first is just the risk of simply
contracting the corona virus so at this
point for most of us that risk does
remain low because the spread is really
localized in four or five main
jurisdictions and clusters plus pop up
cases related to travel to infected
areas I'm sorry mysteries are the CDC
saying that over the next year that many
Americans will be exposed to this virus
and there's a good chance that they will
become sick so the the the chance of
spread it seems to be acknowledged is
going to be high so when we talk about a
low risk that we're talking about that
second type I guess seriousness of
illness so so it's two issues first the
risk of getting it for anyone right now
I said right now is low now that can
change over time as this spreads further
in the United States we of course are
doing aggressive containment and
mitigation efforts at the local state
and national level to prevent or
mitigate that spread I'm sorry to parse
the time frame here but I think we want
to be clear with Americans they should
prepare over the next year right now or
in the next 12 months to be exposed and
potentially become sick from this virus
yes
we've been very clear from day one that
we're going to see further spreading and
we would see more cases the most
important issue right now for your
viewers would be the elderly especially
the medically frail elderly as well as
any individual with certain medical
fragility issues like liver disease
kidney disease diabetes recovering from
cancer or immunosuppressed condition
these are the individuals globally that
we've seen who tend to get the most
severe consequences from getting the
virus most of us if we
contract the virus get mild to moderate
symptoms globally
alright secretary azar thank you very
much thank you